welcome to Tom Pappas come to Papa come
to Papa
hello everybody welcome to another
edition of come to Papa your favorite
show of all shows ever made anywhere at
any time good to see you i hope you're
enjoying your week i hope you're
enjoying your winter I know the people
back east are really taking it in the
chin as they say getting pummeled and
it's gone beyond the cute part it's gone
beyond the oh wow we have a good storm
coming let's get some cocoa let's stay
in tell our boss it's over now it's just
I see and crappy and sad and we're here
to cheer you up from Los Angeles
California with my good pal comedian
actor host drummer all-around good guy
Jonah ray hello hi Jonah I use that we I
did interrupt it look like you're about
to say something else I was guy I was
about to just start plugging some dates
cuz I realize it in plug my big day data
in Seattle I'm playing uh uh parlor live
this weekend nice and then going to the
njpac in New Jersey what's that it's a
performing arts center in newark that's
great utiful place these are bigger
theaters like like fancy that sounds
like a fancy that's a fancy one yeah
that's a fancy one and then my second
show in Chicago the city winery which is
a fancy venue also is it also a wise
it's a no if they they do so wine
there's like the city winery in New York
there's one there's a bunch opening up
around the country nice they're kind of
nice theater kind of places in a lot of
good music acts play nice and so I'm
trying to I'm trying to uh I'm trying to
up my game as far as fanciness is so
he's like you're tired of just big
venues you want to go nice big venue
yeah how's that brought down the sides
of the venue going nicer incredibly
really so yeah I was just gonna plug
some stuff and I'd tell you to go to a
Tom papa calm for all of my dates and
such what you got to do that I'm gonna
save that for about 15 minutes in ok
cool and then I'm gonna go save it for a
real emotional story start me up you
talk about my dad and
rexel be about that reminds you to start
crying yeah city winery well Johnny
you're very funny comedian thank you and
uh I don't know you very well know where
we I'm an admirer of yours you uh do a
lot of funny things you were host on on
the Nerdist Network you had the great
show on comedy central's is still going
yeah we're gonna do a third season the
summer sweet yes the meltdown meltdown
with Jonah Kemal and that's a witch you
guys started out of a the back of a
comic book store and it turned into a
television show yet it's still a show in
the back of a comic book store even
though not there yeah we shoot there we
still do the show everyone's day too I
keep wanting to go by you are always
welcome and I've told you that before
did yeah and uh I don't know what it is
what time is it on Wednesday we started
830 on Wednesdays then and just go yeah
we usually morrow oh please it's it's a
good show tomorrow yeah I'm sure I think
there's a few people on that year that
you know our friends with yeah but it's
at yeah it's a fun show it's like we try
not to go past the two-hour mark usually
we try to rapid I I around ten-thirty
mark it gets real hot in that but you
know back room of a comic book store I
did one show there for all things comedy
with Bill burn al Madrigal that's right
that's right yeah cuz it is kind of just
a space now that people do stuff when I
started there was a like you know my
comedy show and then art shows and then
storage space oh really yeah so what
made you decide to start comedy there
well there was this girl that was a that
I knew that was dating a comic and she
wanted to kind of put on a show there
she was working there and she had me be
the permanent host it was a monthly show
it was uh it was free we had like free
beer that's great and it was it was nice
was on Fridays it was and I took over
and I want to take it weekly but lazy
and then luckily uh Kumail Nanjiani and
his wife Emily Gordon moved town right
there like we were doing a weekly shows
like have I got a place for you and were
you guys pals before that we were
becoming pals it was that thing they had
just moved from New York and I'd met him
a couple times out there very kind of
similar so we I just started seeing a
girl and he was married so say we kind
of went on a couple friend dates nice
and yeah we kind of got along and we
actually became better friends from just
doing the show wow that's cool this app
funny how things are perceived isn't it
like yeah whenever you see like
something else happening somewhere like
free
years I thought like Maria Bamford and
Patton Oswalt were hanging out gonna
pool parties together because the comedy
kiss comedians of comedy and you're at I
was in the East Coast didn't really know
the scene out in la too much and then
you go and you in you talk to Marie
she's like no I i I'm friends with the
grocer yeah I'm the street well that's I
mean that's my perception of new york
ave think everybody hangs out at the
cellar great uh and it's just they're
all friends and that's why everyone's on
everyone show completely forget that
that's basically what happens out here
yeah it's pretty so there I have bad
there is a little bit more of that in
New York I think that cellar dynamic
yeah because it is such a place where
you can just drift into everything on
there yeah always there's no real end up
place here no there's no like diner or
please read out and it's a it is kind of
a bummer I mean that's why my favorite
festival is montrell not because of the
shows right because of that everyone
ends up at that height bar I now and it
feels like a festival yeah feels like
you're running into people as if it was
you know uh music that's where
everything happens on the same day and
you get to hang out and see some people
I like I'm playing The Comedy Store lot
lately which has been great it's
becoming that people are just going
there yeah I don't know where to hang
out though I stand in the hall sometimes
that's the problem I like that front bar
it's not really just comics no you know
what you know is the brilliant stroke of
the comedy cellar because there's the
same similar like the comic stores in
front there's like an outdoor kind of
bar area where someone got shot anything
but uh but most of times just people
hanging out and there's a lot of just
regular people and fans of the show and
it's kind of a loud and chaotic in the
comedian's like if you go over there you
just kind of like you gotta find a
friend and hang on like a life raft yeah
The Comedy Cellar man heed warman God
rest his soul who started the place he
created a table there and he put little
signs up that said Comedy Cellar
comedians only yeah so it didn't even
mean but you couldn't he just be a
comedian you had to be passed at that
Club to be able to sit and hang out at
that table and I've heard many stories
about this table and I've seen it ready
room yeah it's it's not that big no it's
tiny maybe six seats yeah
and you know eight if you stuff them in
there so Whitney but it was a haven like
well I one's trying to come in and now
the shows and you could like go and just
know you could sit there not be hassled
can you talk during the show there and
that because it's upstairs Oh tree
restaurant is upstairs and downstairs in
the cellar is the comedy cellar oh I see
so that table the back tables as a
misnomer it's not it's the back table of
our olive tree right okay yeah it's not
in the showroom yeah no no no no no yeah
I um happenstance I'd like you know when
I first went to New York I didn't know
that I just thought the seller was the
seller I did right there was the true
you know the restaurant above was so but
I was just looking for a place to grab a
beer right and I was like well his
comments to a seller I mean I just went
up to that place and then everybody I
knew kept on walking in I was like yeah
it is pretty great The Improv had that
out here for a while that bar was great
was so great they're going back to it
though oh they are yeah cuz they closed
down they're just doing shows in that
new bar that they tried to make work
into a thing yeah the announcers can be
shows it became a guy go holiday inn
lobby bar yeah that's a that's a thing I
find it with a lot of comedy uh bars or
parties you know they can say oh it's
like coming central stone a party or
this a festival sort of party and you go
and it's not a place that any comic
would want to go to or be in I mean I'm
not an anti-social kind of guy like I'm
very very sociable very gregarious but I
like a any party that a calm essential
or anyone puts on I'm just like I don't
want to be here I don't think anyone
wants to be here worse yeah yeah you
always walk in there's always loud like
intense club music playing yeah and all
comedians want is to be able to hear
each other yeah it themselves mainly
moves out yeah but it's conversation and
you want to hear and you go they did not
want to hear loud music and dance floor
yeah it's packed it's it's that's why
you know when we have our wrap parties
for for the meltdown tapings and I just
like a crappy bar it's over like it just
literally it's in a strip mall so very
yes great that's well it's this war we'd
rather hang out a hundred percent yeah
now do you uh do you pick the axe for
that show or that's Emily we uh Camille
and I hosted together and Emily Gordon
is a producer she's also a writer on
drug Carmichael's that come ah but she's
a you know really
good yeah it's a great show now and
she's you know she's now doing the show
a weekly booking a weekly show and
riding on this well and uh uh it's uh
it's you know it's insane for her but
she still you know keeping it up it's a
but we kind of you know if I see someone
in another show that I think is really
good right I kinda try to my eye on like
younger guys yeah cuz that's a way I'm
an established show can really just dry
up and and not be relevant right is if
you don't also like get a hold and
support the younger comics coming up for
sure I saw I mean it kinda happened I
think with Largo were just became all
the friends and it's that's easy to do
because you just want to hang out with
your friends right but then you know
then the the younger comic start to
resent it young on go find new space you
they find a new space and then the the
general comedy audience gets older and
stops going to shows as much and they
said going to the younger shows right at
you know just I saw as I've seen it
happen so many times with so many shows
that I've wanted to not do that with us
really so interesting I it's amazing how
first it's amazing how it just never
stops but there's just always only crops
of people here pulling into town hungry
rate ready to do shows yes do go
anywhere waves from New York and Chicago
reg yeah it rained exactly dislike hey
I'm ready to go and then you blink your
eyes like you get caught up into doing
like a project or TV show or something
and within like a year and a half you're
like who are all these people yeah it's
in it's incredible and I hate it yeah
it's gotta be cool for you because you
get to at least keep your finger on the
pulse a little bit like just get that at
your show yeah TV show and the live show
it is nice because you kind of start to
see the other little groups and scenes
popping up as kids on the east side I
like Solomon Giorgio and the others like
Eric to Dory nearly oh wow what a cool
in like they'll live in a house together
in highland park and a pro shows on the
ground was like that's a coolest and
then there's this the new crop of guys
that are just like dedicated to go into
the comedy store right now those younger
guys yeah and their elder statesman is a
guy that you went to open mics with
great that that's the part that the you
know I'm now like I think 12 12 13 years
n and it's one of those things were all
of a sudden you're talking to a kid that
kills it on stage and says I remember
seeing your premium blend and your
well how old are you I was seven crazy
isn't it yeah you're like I'm still
trying to not do material from that set
stop trying to cycle myself out of that
isn't it amazing like you don't you know
you don't feel that much older than when
you showed up now right but that might
just be entertainment in general they
think it is it's just perpetual
adolescence especially comedy for sure
yeah but you you have a relationship
right you're in relation yeah I was a
thing I I kind of set out to do i kinda
want to have a life outside of comedy
right I saw eating a lot of friends
alive the road I've been out every night
doing comedy and yeah and I wanted to
make sure I had friends and
relationships in life outside of it
right and they re married yeah been
married almost three years three years
no kids no kids shiz wanna she doesn't
wanna yes I really lucked out with that
wow that's pretty good yeah that's gonna
keep you younger even more I see it but
also I I do see it motivate guys to no
end there sure but you know it's kind of
interesting you know I've got to and
their people now they like you know the
oldest is 13 like they're real people
it's like again and I it doesn't make it
doesn't it hasn't cut down on my
adolescent feeling for myself you know
what I mean it's a strange thing so much
responsibility yeah shut up no II less
selfish for sure yeah I'm always
fighting it there's always like I want
to do so I was thinking about it last
night like it doesn't even matter I just
I just like it I was done with dinner
and my youngest didn't want help with
her homework she was cocky and just like
I'm gonna go do my own thing and I was
like fine and my wife went off to do her
thing and the oldest is just doing her
thing and I'm like all right I'm alone I
can do whatever I want right now I'm
just sitting on the couch i'm like i can
watch whatever i want but then the
feeling of everybody thinking about what
you're doing and where you are it's so
heavy on your chest like an x-ray
blanket that you're you're purely never
completely free yeah you really not yeah
that sounds of like a very you know just
a couple non kid feeling and I have is
that you know when i'm not working and
my wife is working
Ryan I uh have this entire day the
possibilities are endless and I'm
paralyzed by that fact and then I do
nothing I don't even watch TV or movie
or do anything I barely get on my phone
and my wife comes home cuz all the
sudden it's you know 630 right what you
do and my response is always the same as
like you've got some writing done it's
like boys cuz there's no way they can
really check on that knows gonna check
on to see if you really got it right in
there is also named orefice saying it's
like wheelied there you know thought
about things and they not in all honesty
that is part of it now just hanging
around and not you know even if you're
not seeing down the pen and paper just
let her mind wander yeah completely yeah
but there is a limit if you it was so
like she came in and you're playing a
video game and the dishes are piled up
or whatever yeah it's it leaves you with
a shitty feeling it does it does it say
you know like right now the situation is
a that I'm working a lot you know I'm in
an edit bay you know 10 hours a day uh
and my wife is at home and write she's
like she feels that guilt setting in so
she does housework and then gets kid
it's great it's great but then what does
he do she's she's she's an actress but
that she also does animation uh like she
had like a good day job to an animation
she did short for Nickelodeon something
nice but now she's just you know like
doing the acting thing auditions small
parts here and there right so a lot of
free time yeah a lot of free time what
are you editing now I'm editing a show I
made for see so which is the new NBC
digital platform how many thing it's a
cool service it's like got like a ton of
like a huge library full of like british
comedies alright i heard about that yeah
it's it so i sold a show to them or it's
called hidden america with Jonah ray and
to a travel show it's like a Bourdain
but it's a parody oh nice so it's like I
go to all these places around the
country where you go I went to the nine
episodes New Orleans San Francisco
Seattle Los Angeles that one was to save
money Wow but we did Denver Boston
Chicago Atlanta awesome she's so there's
a budget yeah there was a bit of a
budget not a lot right not a lot we like
stretched it and it's essentially
sketches so it's like I go to these
places and I go talk to this guy you
know like it we have Joe
in Chicago episode Bray and he's a guy
that runs the Chicago hot dog place he's
trying to make like the most like crazy
Chicago dog and he's ever for every
ingredient he runs to a different part
of the city and then if you get so
overwhelmed trying to do it that ends up
having a heart attack that's funny it's
like we have you know it's it's a kinda
green now in one words I can we go to
this thing and then it's a sketch and so
you go to the place and use but use
actors from here or New York whatever we
tried mainly to use local oh you did but
you know you can't it's a it are in this
dated you kinda gotta get some cameos in
here and there right we have like some
cool cameos John Anna's Jill tally jeh
Johnson II Roberts cool comedy people uh
right but then you know we also just but
I also love the onion news network
videos where you never recognize any of
the people and now it just kind of gives
it that little sense of fake reality for
real there were so many funny looking
people in comedy like in the beginning
of comedy on in film and radio I talked
about this do you this fact all the time
isn't it's striking it's insane that you
have to be a model to be a comedian I
was go on Sunset and there's like you
know these giant billboards of uh of
comedies coming up on different networks
and everybody is beautiful beautiful
comedies yes I remember like a couple
years ago at Montreal and I saw the
lineup of new faces I was like what's
the prerequisite for being a new faces
is that you also can model for levi's
like just the skinny beautiful people
like where's buddy hackett and Jackie
Gleason and big dog faced people yeah WC
Fields was a monster like I'm so so
surprised he was run out of town all
this nose yeah big craters in it yet one
of our biggest comedy stars in this
country was knit we called him fatty
that's right uh not on that ad well but
now he was a little sad but but like
it's like I think about that all the
time where and in it's no fault too but
I think it kind of started with old
school mm-hmm where they did this thing
where they wanted every small role no
matter what to be filled with someone
that was really funny right and that's
that's admirable and it worked for that
movie yet I became what it is now so now
you got like you know these really funny
moments in these movies but it's you got
this comic is
when his plane a cop right and he shows
up in these is no authority and you're
not like that guy's a cop you're like
that's a funny guy playing a cop correct
where if you look at comedies from the
80s and seventies and yes they got these
character actors that were able to be
fine play to that comedy for sure me so
they felt like a copper they felt like a
clerk yes you know it wasn't just this
uh a look at alt comic as the store
clerk you know being crappy or looking a
look at Yankee playing the Millennial in
this thing yeah it's it felt more real
now it just sounds like everything's uh
you know a Funny or Die sketch words
like the entire community came together
to make something yeah it's got itself
isn't it weird though that like you're
not even talking about network stuff you
know me like Funny or Die videos and
it's still like this incestuous I think
comedy yeah yeah all of it in the movies
like you know like in neighbors it's a
very funny movie over like yeah like
they have you know Hannibal Burres very
like when the funnies comes around is
playing a calm you like that kind of
Hannibal at right way like that's what
you know it's you know it's a good spot
and I mean you do have cameos but like
when you watch Fargo a lot of
weird-looking people yeah you know you
got your your Hanks and a couple other
people but you know like the big it
using like gary valentine playing a cop
yes just you know he's stuffed into that
that uniform yeah buttons are breaking
it's perfect it's you know yeah there's
something about that I tried to do that
a lot with like the hit America show
where you know we were our friend was
helping us with casting as a favor and
Ray she would send me this Lich's like
here's for the the schoolteacher be an
interview right and it's just models and
I just like give me a real person yeah
um yeah give me and I just want I was
like it also give me ugly people getting
weird-looking people exactly it does it
then you're not if they you know there's
one we have one scene in a taqueria it's
like we got these two really authentic
like you know just Latino la people yeah
and then there's just this model she's
one of the most gorgeous people I've
ever seen and it's like you're watching
the country's also near like god no and
you know god bless the beautiful people
they're not funny now coz they didn't
spend a life trying to survive off
something else no they didn't walk into
a room and have people move yeah it
could be smart because they spent a
lifetime trying to convince people
they're smart right
but it is it's I you know let it let the
weird people have something so you happy
with the show would you call on the show
hidden America hidden America I was
trying to think of like kind of a board
a knee you know right parts unknown yeah
America's good thanks yet cuz it's well
ideally I mean originally I you know was
I pitched it to network uh tru TV right
and my whole idea of the show was i was
trying to get real dry and with the name
kind of just doesn't sound like a
comment like a travel show have it be my
name cuz i'm a guy that's hosted some
stuff right and so the idea was like
it's like in America Boston oh cool a
travel show right and you know we tried
we shot it like a board a horse like
real beautiful no real just hyper poetic
ill nice laughing about stuff but just
little dry hidden jokes here and there
uh an idea was like I just want to trick
people with this show yeah I wanna watch
like oh cool guy making gumbo and I
turned out to be like a truth or
conspiracy theorists and equated gumbo
to you know the lizard people come to
Stargate the cumin being the Jews that
run the world kind of thing just there
you are you writing it yeah I wrote it
had really good staff at Matt Dwyers
like an old like second city guy Mike
Mitchell who was on the birthday boys uh
and then uh mark Rivers who you know
he's like done stuff with mr. shows
alcohol yeah ania Troy Miller is
directing in he's got a nice little
pedigree nice and it's good not good
crew yeah so how many people would go
out to the location it would be uh me
one rider was like I was very much like
cuz I'm every scene uh-uh so like the
director the producer uh two camera
people to camera ops in a sound guy okay
real small well that's good yeah and you
can get it done and how long would you
stay in a town like doesn't about it for
days yeah yeah just because it was
setups and then there were so we want it
we also interview people on the street
to kind of you know it's like once you
start hearing a real person talker and
another real person talking start
talking to someone right character you
kind of don't recognize it right away
right kind of a way it's like the whole
thing is just trying to trick people I
think mainly people will be like more
I'll get more huh as opposed to last
that no do my stand I I can see where
that would be funny hilarious how many
did you do 99
well half hours yeah they end up being
you know like 25 minutes but you know
it's digital so she's gonna play out but
I or hopefully you know are you watching
the oj thing I haven't started yet I'm
real behind but I'm excited to see it
when I saw the first trailer for the
teaser yeah I lost my [ __ ] I know me too
I think everyone's kind of feeling that
yeah and what's the only reason I bring
it up is that you're gonna do nine and
then just they'll just dump them all and
you get to watch them all right I think
the way see so is doing is weakly oh
they are doing we are doing a show with
the UH Parsons Brigade and they're
putting those out way cooler it's almost
it's funny that the bed additional TV is
more like I am looking forward to oj my
wife was like is it on tonight my god no
it's not till tomorrow like we're
actually looking forward to it then
Fargo was the same way I that I enjoyed
the tuning in x-files right now enjoy
tuning in I know I don't like I ice too
much the binge culture is it's so it's
so me right now like it's like a I hate
it so much because it ruins the social
aspect our entertainment which is uh
that you know you everyone participated
Adams about what's gonna happen did you
see what happened last week you know
that's what has to robot was so much fun
to watch it too was just what you
something crazy happens you talk about
it for a week and you you know you text
with your friends you talking about Nut
Bars it's great I know now the binge
thing it's like we've got to digest 10
hours before we go out with jen MP yeah
because they're gonna talk about it yeah
it's i don't i don't think it's
conducive to and then you know what it
does is it stifles conversation because
yeah oh you've been watching oranges new
black it's a yeah don't you as a wait
wait would episode you I what episode
you add is like just going to be the
theme for this entire decade wait where
you add on that it really is kind of
Shea this urge a thing it's really like
all right we get to all watch this next
one together yeah it's amazing but it's
kind of interesting it just has to be
good that's all comes down to yes yeah
and I mean cuz like there's a lot of
stuff on network TV that's that way but
you don't get excited about it i don't i
don't know if i watch any network i
guess x files now but yeah you know it's
six episodes not really thing I know
yeah there's no network stuff that's
like I really want to see that mr. robot
where do i get to see mr. robot i'm
totally out of the loop on that USA it's
but we owe on demand on USA yeah you
watch it on demand a thing called
so it's good it's great yet if you like
um you know it's got a fight club vibe
to it rhymes where the artiest shows um
why would say that before the second
season of Fargo came out which was that
it now holds the title is artiest yeah
all the split screen is split screen
multiple angle different takes do you
notice that now it's like you know so
though it'll be the same action right
but different angles different takes
because you see the timing is definitely
interesting yeah which is really good
you know Gary cool ash vs The Evil Dead
also does a lot of crazy awesome artsy
now stuff with Fargo like how many
directors do you think are doing that
season because TV directors do you know
they come in for like one or two and
then they someone else takes it over
that's a good point like who's behind
that structure then yeah cuz that's not
anything that a I mean maybe it's just
the editors are just nailing it maybe
maybe that's something they came up with
after the fam maybe yeah because they're
not using anything different from what
they would have gotten any way yeah yeah
yeah interesting yeah you listen to come
to pop on siriusxm 99 I'm here with my
good pal mr. Jonah ray he's a very
talented comedian which we plug for you
how can people see your wealthy winner I
guess at Jonah ray on twitter at Jonah
ray uh then this uh real proud of my
Instagram yes I need help with my
Instagram I was a good you have no I
like you I like your bit I do look a bit
but it but someone had my name for the
years that I start from when I started
Twitter you know the people had someone
else had my name so it was like the real
Tom papa with five underscores in a
smiley face so Instagram is way behind
my my Twitter and I can't get my
Instagram to catch up very frustrating
it is i mean like there i do it the
ratio is way more on twitter so passive
but i guess so I'm big fan of Instagram
I rather see what someone's up to Oh
someone thinks is a cool thing to
capture you pose to what someone thinks
of something in 140 characters you're
very good yeah at huge news and I hope
it's still huge news it's still
happening what does it know it wasn't a
traditional funding for a show one of my
fav favorite show
of all time and most comedy people's
favorite shows of all time a lot of
comedy people was mystery science
theater yeah and joel hodgson and did
this amazing show where he was stuck in
a space station I think it was a
punishment and he had sit with rubber
bands yeah right they didn't like him
say the shot him into space he had twice
it's horrible it was the beginning of
Comedy Central i believe was the first
place i saw it right yeah actually it
was a chance on comedy channel right or
huh or maybe it was yeah maybe cuz Allen
Havey comedian Allen Havey yeah I had
like the first talk show on ha that's
right but like I'm commie channel like
got together real fast right yeah much
together and then became Comedy Central
actually and the one of the funniest
shows ever and they would just see the
silhouette of these characters watching
these horrible horrible movies which
were great movies and they would comment
it was the funniest comment since and
it's just a comedic treat because then
they come back to the space station and
do this thing great show huge uh comedy
following and then everybody was waiting
for it to come back now and now it's
coming back and you're gonna be the guy
yeah you're gonna be the hell you gonna
Joel's part yeah I'm gonna be the new
human uh that you know Joel then Mike
now me uh it's the show crazy it's the
craziest thing so great thanks I I don't
know it's it's funny because it's it was
my favorite show right and you know I
remember I I saw the movie in the
theaters I was like happened to be
visiting really like relatives in carson
city nevada and I was like this thing is
playing in Reno drive me to Reno I have
obvious I was when did that come out it
was a thing came out 98 so 16 rain some
of them so great yeah maybe you know I
can't remember but it's just it's like
it's only drive me though me it meant so
much to me so I was a huge fan of weird
al still am but you know weird I was
like you know I love music I got to make
fun of music with weird out I loved
movies and old sci-fi like crappy B
movies and I got to make fun of them
in and I have friends right but like
buddies but when when you're alone in
your room yeah you still are hanging out
and it's it's funny the first meeting I
ever has i start doing comedy in 2002
okay maybe like two thousand three or
four i started i think the the comedy
death-ray bang bang show started I was
like kind of a part of that scene and
right and I was uh on an improv team a
UCB your you know uh and I had like my
first meeting like a manager said hey
like a you're really funny come in and
meet with us as uh uh you know agency
and I I sit down and like so what would
you do the whole thing yet what would
those Jonah ratio be what would it be
what it be like you know your it was
like a hipster was just like a brand new
term yeah the time it was fresh yeah a
hipster hipster life's two lakes alike
you know they're still say las pilas cuz
you know there was a few other night
yeah and uh you know like you work at
working at a record store them would be
wrecked store would be a lie and I was
like no no no actually know that because
that's a that'll be dated immediately
right and uh it's for people are
watching CBS yeah exactly yeah I'll just
I remember saying like I was like I
don't really want to personify my my
youth culture because I want to become
the next barry sobel never take on it
that's funny I don't want to be like you
know 20 years from now like being like I
like the bz boys still we're in the cool
jacket from the eighties yeah so and
they thoroughly what do i do I said well
I think in this is in 2003 and it'll
only been off the air for you know a
little bit I was like I think we should
bring it back I think we should redo it
all be the host mr. science 3000 it's
and they laughed at me no that's never
going to happen really i'll give credit
they did say like it's too long people's
attention spans are that long anymore so
stupid yea rold them anybody's just to
get off track for a second anybody's
philosophy of what people can endure and
will accept from entertainment is is
wrong yes unless they say it's just
gotta make it great yeah if you make it
great inukami of you make it really
funny mmm you could serve it up an hour
long with no commercials you could serve
it up in two minutes with whatever it is
yeah just because has nothing to do that
for me
at or any of that other no it just it's
like the idea of like uh you know one
liner comics being a little bigger ilet
will read in the like two early two
thousands and a lot of one liners exact
dimitri gonna dance DJ novak like yeah
everyone was doing quick joke yeah and I
member people that's the way it is now
people don't have time for store and I
remember like number like pleading with
my friends like I'm not smart enough to
write a one-liner reckoning to charm the
audience with a story I have a different
thing yeah yeah yeah but I guess money
and it doesn't matter yes that doesn't
matter yes so funny so they laughed you
out of the room they line this is like
2003 Aurora some of that and uh and you
know so like three years ago or so me
and joel hodgson became you know
acquaintances um he was on the Nerdist
podcast okay and then I actually ran
into him at an art show for a Wayne
white and Wayne white he was the guy
that designed pee-wee's Playhouse needed
the sledgehammer video really he's a
he's one of those guys were it's like if
you go back and you're like oh he's done
all this stuff you ever been to fred 62
and Lily's you know those those
paintings with the three-dimensional
words right that's him too hes and he
has a great documentary on called beauty
is embarrassing really and it's really a
one of the best documentaries I've seen
about just like not art as in painting
or you know sculpture just the artist
life and uh um allowing yourself to just
be a part of it real and doing scalding
it's called beauty is embarrassing
beauty is embarrassing yeah and it's
just a gorgeous like you know it's yes
just like he's like do stuff because
it's it makes you excited not because of
sales or answer that it's just it's a
real great inside and kind of
inspirational yeah very inspirational
maybe come up with like it like a term I
say in my head a lot these days which is
a make stuff not money right um never so
diverse thing women's yeah score
acceptance speech yeah and I I truly
believe that it's only ever pointed me
in the right direction yeah I was like
taking a lot of money jobs writing on
like crappy you know magazine TV shows
like I know ed you know comedic
entertainment infotainment stuff yeah no
II Angie for expert evilly all the only
tertiary yeah but in the beginning it's
a gig right
getting some was gonna give you some
money in you yeah keep your artistic
life alive yeah you like I can be kind
of funny at work and then I can go and
be funny at night yeah my own and use
you realize that just like you'll you as
you progress it's it's kinda like the
thing you wanted yeah not but you don't
you can't tell the difference for a
while now again paid for the first time
if you don't have your eyes open it ends
up devouring the real creative part of
ulit I had a friend that you know it was
just one of those things reality
television like it just like it say oh I
got hired because like I'm I'm funny
while they're shooting some like these
reality show stuff and then he became a
story because he's a funny guy and then
they got a job like at the company
because he's like they're like you're
funny you can be like a cry and it's now
hey John it's now just he's dislike suit
at a place and he's kinda like man I
just wish we like I'm not like trying
cousin try and put together a movie
right now and yeah it was uh he's like
man like I should have made a mother you
still can like cami though has he built
up a life around those paychecks from
the company where's kind of the gilded
cage I don't know it's like it's very
possible III don't think anyone truly is
but I think a lot of people feel that
they feel that way for sure yeah and so
you know allowing myself to just kind of
pursue what made me creatively fulfilled
as opposed to write my pocket just yeah
so I'm sorry you met him oh just too
white yes though I met him at like a
Wayne white art show and then I saw in
the next night at a harmontown taping I
just have to swing by Dan Harmon's
podcasts now say hi and he was there and
then a couple weeks later you know we
chatted there he's like oh hey man you
know yeah uh couple weeks later Hardwick
you know text me saying hey Joel just
asked me for your number so you might be
calling you well geez I'm just sitting
at my desk is working at the soup at the
time I was writing all right I'm just
you know avoiding watching clips of the
biggest losers like that I know when I
first work in their side but are they
like you can what you can have the
biggest loser that could be when the
shows you look through four clips I was
like well they must trust me that's a
big show I realize it's like you can't
make a joke about that show cuz you're
only gonna make fun of fat people am I
the only one I was able to cobble
together was like look how much this guy
sounds like he's uh
when he's on the treadmill got away the
one thing they're like no sorry how long
we hit the sea house there for a year
for you I gave myself a year yeah I
loved everyone they're like hey Anderson
is great ray it's a great group of
people they were all done now right
they're done yet Joel's last one and
they're all I mean I really love that
show just because and that just your
part was funny too just because you know
I don't watch any of those shows ever
yeah so for a half hour a week to sit
and watch really funny takes on and then
really able to see clips of is like I'm
all caught up ya know I feel the same
way like it's like I enjoyed work on a
show and I I got I got some really funny
stuff that i'd make a video uh with uh
vanilla ice words i did this whole me in
my friend Paul uh we rode this thing
words like vanilla tries to restart like
he was a rapper then he tried to do the
hard heavy metal kind of stuff right now
he's trying to do an indie rock thing so
we like you know we got vanilla ice I
put him in one of my you know Western
button up shirts and we put him in the
in the back of a bookstore in echo park
and we had our friend Mike Henry like
playing acoustic guitar and he was like
singing ice ice baby but like real
thoughtful yeah real tough oh yeah so I
got to do we really like that honey but
uh but yeah it's a you know I'm waiting
for the phone to ring it's like it rings
from a number I don't recognize him
hello easy hey man hi Joel hey anyway
just easy i just want to say is really
nice mania is really cool blonde and
then that was it he just sees they re
well yeah maybe i'll come to town we'll
hang out Oh max nobody's in Minnesota
still no he's in he's been in
Pennsylvania the password Pennsylvania
okay and it was just one of those things
where you know then like I went out to
comic-con in New York to do like a show
then he's a hey let's go get dinner
right so me and my wife got dinner and
then you know he would call me every
once while many all during this time
he's just saying you know I'm think
about bringing it back i'm trying to get
the rights back from you know Jim Mallon
and you know just and it was just the
slow process of you know it happening
over a course of a few years is he funny
just hanging out he's really funny I you
guys actually have like a mutual friend
and Jerry yes he's guys could pass a
cherry yeah so he loves like he he loves
jokes like he loves lego like he loves
stopping a
conversation to kind of figure out all
angles on a funny thing that was just
sad Breaking and like it's like you it's
it could be in the middle of like a
conversation that was going or as a way
way man wait wait it's awesome yeah it's
it's really he's just such a he's ooh I
don't like using the term genius but
like yeah really like he thinks in these
crazy weird obscure broad strokes of
stuff like this is what its gonna be and
like I don't even know how the picture
that happen again and then he kind of
starts whittling it down and then when
he's done with it it's just this perfect
little idea how interested but he has to
talk it out with everybody all the time
it's pretty so it's me so as he's
talking through all this stuff and you
have this you know admiration for the
show even before he it becomes a real
thing is he ever talk about maybe I'm
going to bring the show back and you
could be the host or is it just maybe
I'll bring the show because maybe I'll
bring the show back and i was like i was
saying yeah I mean that's others a lot
of people think they would love that
yeah and then and you know um hope I'm
not overstepping bounds might say all
happy happy to be involved in any way
right you know I'll PA oh just to have
it you know there's like there's mu
there's those comedy things that you
want to do in your career we just want
to like tic little boxes all right and
one of my buses was like working on a
show like that yeah and so I go say
anything you want anything you want yeah
and then he use again oh yeah maybe you
could like you know right because we
kind of wrote some jokes together once
and he was like a really funny really
you know on real quick as maybe you
could write I was like yes anything
anything yes like you know months will
go by yeah i was thing about it so you
know so i can sell some of your videos
that you can probably direct some of the
episodes and like maybe help produce
lousy any please yes and then one day he
just casually were talking it's just
phone calls over the course of months
and months in a couple years and they
use that yeah I just think I realize
it's like too old to do this man I can L
took Mike's 20 is it's it's like it's
gotta be like refresh its Doctor Who
it's Saturday Night Live you know it's
he's right and he goes I just realize
it's like you know we need a new doughy
white guy to be on camera should
probably just be you and I was like was
Anna
he's is it is it just makes sense and
and then as I was sure but even from
that moment was still like maybe a year
and a half before it was even official
and those there's different iterations
of how it was gonna work like maybe a a
live theater of real live mr. signs here
in Philadelphia where I live for you
know while and yeah he just can't like I
say he does he has his big ideas any
kind of whittles it till it make sense
and it made sense to bring it back
pretty much as it was right as a show
yeah it's going to be the same show I
mean it's a it's all about the riffing
on of movies and uh and you know he he
was asking I was like why gonna get
trays uh for crow or is a good bill
Corbett for analyzing know it's like you
know you gotta it's like you said doctor
who SAT night live yeah and so he said
like he's a who would you think for crow
and I said I can only think of one comic
his name is Hampton Yount right and he
said he already sounds and acts like
well yeah hey as I was a who you
thinking for uh Tom servo he's like I
don't know I just I just think he should
you know to me Tom's always been black
man it's like well I know a guy that
they're gone just like that's good yeah
like a theatrical you know singer guy
and you know so yeah it's the same so
now what's the next step well I right
now there are shopping it around I was
like a couple like really cool places
that are interested so the going to work
it out you know great and uh that's a
kind of interesting thing most of the
shows our projects have ever done I've
been in so much control yet this I'm you
know I'm like a hired host and writer so
just like tell me when the job star
isn't that like such a relief it's them
especially right now working on the
hidden America show where I am
responsible for everything yeah I'm the
meetings and all in and the work and all
the stuff just to no.7 in those
situations where all of a sudden then
you get hired yeah and you're just like
all right Tom word we're done and you
you know when you leave there gonna be a
meeting yesterday they're gonna be
ordering dinner yeah you're just done
you're way off a lot yeah it is such a
different thing yeah it is and I right
now I miss it but I know there's gonna
be another time where I like I'm like I
just wish I could tell them that what
they just did this
they are they just move the camera this
were to use that way out oh it's such a
cool thing though and what's he is right
i mean to freshen it up I mean cuz
everybody wanted to see a seinfeld
reunion then you got a little dose of it
on curb everyone wanted arrested
development to come back and it's just
like when they come back it's just like
that's almost what we want yeah if we
could just a frozen everybody yeah it
really like I can't and you know I think
I think x-files is doing a pretty good
job yeah of coming back yeah but he
still can't there's a little party looks
like the faces are just different yeah
it is like seeing like a man that you
saw as a kid you see him now and you're
like you look around the room you're
like oh everyone's dying yeah everyone's
gonna die they're gonna die on the
they're not even I used to think these
guys are so old and early five years
older than me I know and it's like it
would be one thing if they come back and
they're just playing themselves ten
years later but they come back and they
still doing the same stick and there's
trying to do the same romance or
whatever it is yeah our to come back but
you for your show to like just be a
fresh face and a new guy that's been
punished and sent into space it's gonna
be great yeah yeah and to BP punished by
you know Felicia Day and Patton Oswalt i
think is a is gonna be a lot of writing
yes i can't i can't believe it and it's
I feel like I'm and so I'm like I feel
like I'm lucked out I've lucked out so
much that I'm lucked out right okay good
I just cuz I got you know a weird i was
one of my childhood heroes yeah i'm in a
video that my friend Eric Appel directed
that al shows at his concerts now so
you're in Al's and I I'm in elle's
concerts and I'm like I've worked with
them a few times like I've got to write
in a Kia and now I'm going to be you
know a mr. senator like a fact that it's
like I think it's uh it's crazy that Mel
Brooks announced spaceballs too because
that's the other one that's like racer
sincere way down Mel Brooks though
that's like the trifecta of me that's
what makes me who I am right right and
so uh like now I'm just going like I I
was on the way here thing like emailing
my agent as going if I don't even show
if I should if I don't
in the background not like I want to be
one like it was like who hears [ __ ]
yo I understand why those guys if I
don't show up I'm gonna fire all of you
it's a great email the right yeah and I
am I'm gonna do it I'm gonna see who
calls my bluff ok I'll see which ones
have a sense of humor you listen to come
to pop on siriusxm 99 I'm here with my
good pal mr. Jonah ray very funny
comedian you could follow him on Twitter
you should follow him on Instagram got
some good videos on there and he's gonna
have a new show coming out called hidden
America with Jarrah with Jonah ray when
do people be able to see this last I
heard july july yeah first i heard was
january then marched in june july which
it was told me that when i was writing
it at a breakneck speed right exact but
falls out yeah but it's on it's gonna be
on see so calm which is cool cool yeah
it's got like you know tons of great
stuff on there that's awesome uh I just
got back from Hawaii that's where I was
born and raised where I just did a gig
in Maui okay never been never been now
you don't go you don't go island to
island I went to quiet once cuz my dad
um what a contest at work right he got
like a hotel in Kauai right so we did
that and then I went once with my band
took Hawaii and then we went to the big
on all the time because we had family
out there okay that was like they're
only reason we would ever go to the Big
O so going to the other islands is like
going to any vacation destination kind
of thing for you like it's like I'm not
going I mean we it's like it's very
similar it's like it's a it's like if
you took your family down to heighten
beach right you know for a vacation it's
just like right why would I we could
sleep at home it was just another Beach
there's more water describe your home
growing up my homegirl yeah uh it was
when we first moved in it was a it was a
nice size house and across the street
from kind of a crack neighborhood oh
really a real run down real sketchy area
my dad bought a lot in this spot they
eventually pushed everybody out of that
neighborhood and
uh so for a while we were living across
from like a whole abandon air hood which
is great kid going in breaking stuff
emison cool many all-star getting lit on
fire right and then they tore it all
down and then they turn it into a park
and then our house was across the street
from a park that led to the beach really
yeah how old were you then uh when that
happened I was probably 13 13 yeah so
the beach is literally a parks distance
from your house yes you yeah it was nuts
and my dad we could almost see the water
and there was these kind of tall pine
trees covering the our view of the water
and so my dad once woke up my brother in
the mill the ninth and they went across
the street and my dad started a chain
sawing down now yeah he told my brother
is like when you see flashing lights
tell your dad and then we'll run and say
just started take it he took down two
and it was in the machine in the papers
like it's like someone's to mow down
trees on Kailua Beach that is awesome
yeah but how do you dad end up in Hawaii
born raised there whoever is there
really yeah yeah of roots yeah my
family's been Hawaii a few generations
maybe uh for uh early early plantation
workers from portugal in the Azores ever
and yeah real Hawaii so much it's the
it's one of the most magical beautiful
places and it's also alarmingly messed
up and dirty at the same time yeah you
know it's kind of strange like I've been
going to Maui for a while I guess I've
been a kowai just watching it get more
and more developed and all of a sudden
like the ride from out of the airport
you almost want to shut your eyes like
this isn't who I just keep going just
keep going to get out of all this I
don't need to see the strip malls in the
subway sandwich shop but even that I
mean I'm exaggerating some degree but it
is like you don't you just want to you
want the picture you just painted of
looking through a park and just seeing
the ocean yeah yeah exactly you know in
you know my town going back home it's
it's developed now there's a starbucks
there's a target which I can't even in
my head oh yeah we had a small little
suburban town on the windward side of
the island and you know it's yeah it's
still beautiful it's still there's no
metal yeah you it's is in your mind is
the nature and what it is so
overwhelming that a
you always going to be more powerful
than target and costco I think so I um I
really think so it's a you can you know
you can't build on the sand all right
can't build on the water right you can't
build like the the billions upon
billions of stars you're able to see in
the sky there you can't build on that
you can track that out you can't those
mountains you know there's you can't
even know outdoor advertising yeah no
billboards it's great it's a great place
so magical do you feel like do you get
back pretty often not as much as I like
my parents now live in an apartment in
waikiki which is uh to places I'd rather
not stay like I love my parents there
yeah hazing but it's like and I'm
staying in a two-bedroom apartment in
the last place I would want to be in
Hawaii yeah you want to feel I'll go
back home which is like my house feels
like a vacation rental as I could do
that but that'd be really odd it would
be here is really it's a vacation rental
it's weird you could go rent it I could
and I don't know if I would be weird
yeah it would be I think about it
sometimes yeah I don't know if I could
come to terms of doing that I mean I
loved it ever since people came there
its toys in a process of change in
development sure and I think people seem
to want to preserve it too I think
there's forces that want to rape it and
make money off of it but I think there's
an seems like there's enough I mean that
guy that guy from Oracle that just
bought lanai oh he bought 1i he bought
the whole yeah island so now it's not in
the family anymore huh now that's a
bummer I know yeah I know but maybe he's
you know it put in a couple quiet four
seasons they're building their building
four season there there's I think to God
yeah yeah I think Molokai is the one
that's going to be holding strong that's
gonna be the place that's gonna be I
think the last battleground I mean Big
Island sure because it's so huge yeah
it's so big and yeah my i still have
cousins that live out there and uncle
and add that live in you know kamuela
which is the parker ranch it's like you
know you're not even in Hawaii at that
point you're different you're just in
this yo suburb no no not even summer
you're just you're just in the sticks
you're like you're just surrounded by
farms oh really
as far as you can see ya kinda make out
Monica in the distance various like all
this just horses and cows everywhere and
I'm in a Beecher mountain it's just it's
a rare place right but uh yeah it's a
it's on I don't know I i kinda and very
much i love Hawaii and I think it's one
of the most beautiful pretty places you
must feel tied to it in your soul I
would think yeah yeah it's it's funny
i'm glad you you said that because it's
uh it's true i think it's there's a
connection that you have with it that
you can ever shake and yeah you know
when you meet someone else that's grown
up there and it's not gonna yeah and i
always have to deal with that question
too because my mom she moved there when
she was 13 with her family okay um but
like a white lady she was a white lady
right my dad was you know Brown
Portuguese guy right and that's why I
like my last name is rodriguez which is
like the muriqui's version Rodriguez
yeah which was fine in Hawaii everyone
said it the right way when I got here
start sign up for open mike rodriguez i
go well that's gotta change hey ya to
cut a lot of this off yeah yeah luckily
my middle name is ray which like if i
did use my middle name is my last name
it just makes me seem that much more
white right but uh it's uh yeah I am it
is like having family that's been there
for so long yeah and it's a and knowing
the kind of places knowing the law in
the history like I'm so glad that they
made a law while I was going to school
that you had to take Hawaiian history
and and i did a drunk I did drunk
history on comer central right and I did
the episode of hawaii and I you know I
gotta see that one it's it's it's great
but it's once I found out that the other
two you know narrators storytellers no
one was Kurt Braunohler camera or the
other one was but it's like three white
guys well the history of Hawaii and I
can't and okay so I I did my best I I
called friends that you know what's you
H and I said can you put me in touch
with the wine histories professors right
I did like a lot of research for mine
and I want to tell my story through the
perspective cool of the Hawaiians when
Captain Cook showed up and some of them
while you were really drunk or we just
told you had the straight part of it i
know i did that i was really drunk when
i spoke a lot of pigeon when i was doing
it and they're like you shouldn't do
thats racist i was like it's not racist
we talk to them like I called my dad and
my dad like spoke pitching okay oh
that's funny yeah now I tell you it's
such a great place and think about I
don't know what it is I don't I couldn't
live there I have a hard time even
living here and up but I have I mean
that bye I'm my soul is connected to the
east coast like it has this new york
kind of it just where did you grow up i
wore my black comes from again oh right
outside in that in new jersey in north
jersey about 20 minutes it's a lot of
the city yeah so i'm in that energy
right that's my kind of safe place yeah
we're Mike Witts it's just who I am I
guess yeah when I am out here looking
out of my back door at palm trees and
when I'm in Hawaii listening to Hawaiian
music and the stars I just I bliss out
too much I bliss out mmm it's hard for
me to keep the fire the creative fire
going yeah and I'm not lazy but I I
could there's an there's a pull towards
why work so hard you need a certain
amount of misery I think so yeah our
stress you have that at all probably not
cuz you're you work hard you're always
hustling and doing stuff yeah but I try
I try to do it and you know that's the
thing you know Chris Hardwick is one of
the hardest workers I've ever met in my
life right and you know being friends
with him like and we clash a lot with
about like you know work ethic and I you
know I say so much a he's like told me
off and he's like he's lazy you can't
live your life like a punk rock drummer
and I'm like my responsible watch me I
think it's very important to to in the
end you know it's a we're all gonna die
it's a I have any kind of like a I kind
of refer to myself as a optimistic
nihilist uh-huh or it's like you know
nothing means anything so why bother or
you know like why not having a good time
yeah throughout the course of it see try
and enjoy yourselves yeah which i think
is a very Hawaiian thing it's like yeah
no worries you know right
relax just kind of take it easy and it's
a difficult thing especially in our work
because so you know Mystery Science
Theater aside all the other stuff is
really self-generated yes stuff that you
but it's also back to your friend mr.
white it's also if it's an art and
artists you can kind of feel lazy at
some times and enjoy life and still have
a lot of output true the the for the the
trick is not getting full of anxiety
about not doing anything in those
moments dad is very say it again try and
try not to let those moments of doing
nothing yeah that you've earned yes I
not to let those fully fill you with
anxiety because you're a man oh man that
is a bad something I battle all the time
yeah it's tough just yesterday was like
84 degrees it's Monday which technically
is my day off because been working all
weekend yeah and the week is kinda
starting and you just have like that
little blip where you can just kind of
do nothing and it's 85 I should just sit
in the damn chair for five minutes and I
can't do it without having that feeling
of like we should be hustling wish we do
nothing and what did you do in that five
minutes that really couldn't have what
yeah nothing yeah I do my best to be
able to sit and the this is a weird um
analogy but I was once sitting at a
stoplight and I found myself all the
time like when i get my car getting real
fast and like yeah I craig-carroll fast
when I walk from my car to the office I
walk real fast and the when I'm trend
like throw away something like you know
what Johnson I saw a guy an old man um
thrown away like a big box um to any was
trying to cut it up and break it apart
to fit it into a recycling can write but
and I saw the way he was doing it yeah
just like had a box cutter yeah I'm just
cutting it when today he was doing all
the stuff it was like he was just so
content to just do it right and just
have it be done and let the thing that
he's doing be the thing he's doing and
have that be done then go on to do
something else and I think about this
man yeah all the time at it like it's
like especially almost not to like make
it a perfect that like you know just
like one for one but like when I was
taking part of bucks I like I go down
heard it apart not being on it yeah like
staples going in my hand it's like an i
try to I try to quit I think about that
guy whenever I'm doing anything I just
like take your time don't worry about it
yeah into it I mean look if you're hard
with Chris saying you can live your life
like a UH para comer if you are the
purely punk rock drummer you know maybe
maybe yeah maybe yeah because but you
have enough sense and enough going on
structure in your life where you can
kind of live that way as much as you can
yeah I find it important i find you know
like on saturday i could have got some
stuff done because i've been in an
office you had to pay for so long but
you know I want to do I want it was nice
out yeah I want to just drink during the
day with my friends so I went to a
couple bars during the day that had a
nice outdoor patio perfect and it's
there's nothing more lovely than the
ability and freedom to do that as the
best well I have to say you're really a
very cool guy and you know watch your
stuff in wanted to get to know you for a
long time we got to do that a baked
potato show without selvaggi where I
watch you drum your ass off the hair set
using you as a thank you but you got to
say I got a little yeah a little bit Joe
Cocker which was terrifying in fun those
eyes you did the lid back you can do
that Linda but uh yeah hopefully we'll
get to work more and and do stuff
because I I think I want to uh I think
you're ultimately going to end up having
a place in Hawaiian I want to be invited
I am I don't know what it is but
something about this trip do I it was
only a 2 3-day thing now it it tipped me
over to the and you know what it
connected this environment to that yeah
it's I mean there's a lot of similarity
if you look at it in the certain way
certain majors yeah this is very like
you know you gotta take a certain angle
on LA ya feel like wine that's why I
love like the Highland Parker which I
live in because I got those I got the
same gabriel mountains right there and I
got the palm trees and it feels like y
plus it's like yeah latino and lay back
right very Hawaiian you know laid-back
very cool well this is great everybody
uh follow Jonah on uh on Twitter and
Instagram look for his new show coming
out in July will plug it all and give
you
updates as we get closer that's it for
now enjoy your life goodbye
you